this is tony michaels from the tony
michaels podcast on the midas touch
network we have student debt relief for
american working families today the
biden administration has announced their
student loan debt relief plan
it will will provide the american
working families in this country that
make under 125 000
from 10 up to 20 000
of student debt relief
that they will receive also
anyone making under 75 000 90
of those benefits will benefit those
folks who still have student debt relief
let me give you a few key parts of this
program the the main part of this
program is the 43 million people still
have outstanding debt and 60 of those
have pell grants which will get up to 20
000 of that benefit who are making under
25 000
45
of all federal student loans will be
potentially gone from the books so 45
percent of people who still have student
debt in this country federal student
loans will no longer have that debt
under these programs which in fact a
third of the debt in this country
a third of the debt in this country have
no degrees attached to them what that
means is the american working class have
worked so hard in this country they have
worked so hard to have a college degree
and paid the price of those student
loans for so many years and still did
not receive a degree they will have
relief from this package as well another
significant part of this plan that i
think is very and vitally important that
instead of 10
of your income that will go towards the
payment of your of your student loan
five percent so it'll be lowered from 10
to 5 to half
of your of your household income that
will be reduced so not only will this
program give you debt relief on the
total principle of your balance but also
it's going to give people debt relief in
the monthly payment that they pay the
other significant benefit of this
program is that there is a cap of years
that you can pay for student loans this
is very important this is exactly what
the american people have been looking
for and even a president in a time of
great economic success with record low
unemployment rates is still making sure
he's delivering for the american people
today and he's doing it in a contrast of
our last administration who passed a tax
bill in 2017 that did the exact opposite
of this plan gave money to the rich gave
money to people that earn over 125 000
now today president joe biden
delivers on a campaign promise to
deliver the american working class a
program that will directly benefit them
and help them through this economy
as we as we barrel out of this pandemic
as we barrel through this great economy
with low unemployment rates rising wages
and now and now the american people can
be reassured that they will not be
saddled with the student debt that they
have so long to have relief from so
president joe biden the administration
today you're laying out this plan uh in
stark contrast to what the republicans
and the naysayers on both sides will say
because there are naysayers on both
sides today the republicans are acting
like this is the
worst thing that could ever happen to
the american people as if for some
reason for some reason people getting
debt relief on their student loans to
advance them themselves into the economy
is a bad situation and then you have
some on the left that say all or nothing
really if you think about it again
45
of all student loan debt under this
program will be wiped away so 45 percent
of the people who still have federal
student loan is going to have full
relief which relieves them of that debt
it relieves them of that burden so they
can move on they can move on with their
lives and go into the economy and be
confident be confident about their
economic situation so president joe
biden in the biden administration
delivering of campaign promise today to
the american working class and the
american working class i'm sure will be
happy for it thank you for tuning in
here on the midas touch network again
i'm tony michaels with the tony michaels
podcast don't forget to follow my
podcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the midas
touch facebook page just go over to
youtube and type in the tony michaels
podcast subscribe there until next time
thank you very much hey maddest mighty
emma silverman here reminding you to
make this november rovember
check out the new midas touch rovember
t-shirt collection at
store.midastouch.com
that's
store.midastouch.com hurry up and get
your rovember t-shirt before they sell
out let's go
[Music]
you